what's going on guys this is Robin as
you guys know whenever we make our
Deadpool videos whenever we talk about
Deadpool we cast aside all the
seriousness in our videos we cast aside
the instructional method of the videos I
don't know why I'm saying we I cast
aside the instructional method of the
videos and instead we replace it with
humor and so what we're going to be
doing as our lead up to Deadpool kills
Deadpool is we're going to be doing the
different versions of Deadpool the
characters that make up the Deadpool
Corps because the Deadpool Corps will be
a main part of Deadpool kills Deadpool
in that story so without further ado let
us jump into it the first character
we're going to be doing in this video is
going to be dog pool
so dog pool comes to us and pre lewd to
the Deadpool Corps in issue number three
now normally I would do this in terms of
their appearances and chronology but
because of the fact that each stories
dedicated to different characters it
doesn't really matter whether we do in
order or not so because I think dog pool
is the coolest character like the
coolest concept of the Deadpool Corps
we're just going to start with him now
what we do here is we pick up with a man
named dr. Braun and what's taking place
in this alternate reality which of
course the numerical designation isn't
really given to us here is the dr. Braun
is basically trying to establish a
concept of I guess self-replicating or
self restoring mascara and he's creating
this for a company called babbling which
is I guess an alternate reality or a
parody on a company Maybelline which
it's it's like that like that course
you're like maybe she's born with it
maybe it's mabeline I don't know why I
made that joke anyway the fact remains
that what happens here is that this
project is basically very similar to the
super-soldier project from the earth-616
continuity and so what happens here is
that dog pool is subjected to this he's
subjected to this chemical VAT but the
problem is that as far as dr. Braun's
concerned it seems as though it's
basically failed and that this self met
I guess self repairing or self replacing
mascara project is going to be a total
failure and so what they do is they take
this dog that's been named Wilson and
they throw it in the dumpster in the
back and so what happens again with
these alternate reality stories is that
as The Watcher is giving us this
narrative as he's telling us what it is
is taking place here that that this dog
that Wilson basically breaks out of the
bag in which he was in telling us he has
a healing factor and begins to go about
and explore the world around him and so
what we're basically told here is that
this dog is referred to as Deadpool
Merc with a bark so so what happens here
is we is we pick up with this is
ridiculous we pick up with dog pool as
he's basically traversing as he's
walking around and as he's trying to
figure things out with a problem here is
that every time he comes across anyone
they look at him in his physical form
being sort of disgusting as a result of
having been electrocuted and so on and
so they basically ignore him entirely or
they run him off and so what
and so what happens here is the watcher
tells us that Wilson had bad dog poo
begins to have dark thoughts presumably
he's considering suicide because his
life is at this point where he doesn't
see a reason to live this is absolutely
ridiculous and so what happens here is
he runs out in front of a car and he's
hit by a car now what happens as a
result is that the car keeps on going
but he's found by a couple guys who work
with a circus
now we're not explicitly told what the
circus is or who it belongs to because
in truth it's not really important what
happens here with the circus is that
once the dog pool immediately recovers
again you do his healing factor they're
caught an amazement by the fact that he
was able to come back to life from this
and so what they begin doing is
subjecting dog pool to all these
different sort of attractions basically
and dog pool is really interested in
this because for him it's a place of
belonging he feels like he actually
belongs somewhere as part of this circus
and so we see him jumping through rings
of fire we see him being subjected to I
guess to knife throwers and different
things like that and anytime that he's
injured here the fact remains that he's
basically able to heal himself due to
his healing factor and so what happens
is that ultimately dr. Braun is present
in the circus as they're watching this
event take place whereby the healing
factor of a dog pool is effectively put
to the test when they set him on fire
and so because he heals almost
immediately we find that dr. Braun
realizes that his experiment was a
success that in fact dog pool is this
new generation of guests of people that
have healing factors a dog that have
healing factors and so as a result they
can basically put this to use with
regards to the military industrial
complex and so what happens is that once
the circus show begins to come to an end
dr. Braun and his assistant try to
capture dog pool and dog pool attacks
the two of them and then runs them off
and so as a result they go back to the
drawing board and they basically create
a dog version of Wolverine and so what
they do is they travel back to the
circus with this dog version of
Wolverine and they have this dog version
of Wolverine immediately attack a dog
pool and so as the two of them start to
fight what dog pool does you see almost
seems to basically
come here he's almost totally defeated
by by the dog version of Wolverine and
in fact and a very interesting turn of
events
dog Wolverine apparently has adamantium
claws and so he pops his adamantium
claws and we get the signatures snick
and he again continues to chase dog pool
and so what happens is dog pool
basically tricks tricks dog Wolverine
into the interior of a cannon and then
he barks at one of the circus assistants
which indicates that I guess he wants a
circus and a circus assistant to set off
the cannon and so as a result dog
wolverine goes flying into the air and
and that's the end of him he ends up in
a vat any kind of disintegrates and then
that's that and so what we find is that
the real deadpool wade wilson from the
earth-616 continuity appears and he
basically says he's here to grab dog
pool so that they can save the
multiverse and that's where the story
ends so that's the origin of dog pool
that's pretty much the story it's weird
it's a little strange a dog that's like
Deadpool and has a healing factor but
what we're going to do in the next video
is we're going to focus on kid Deadpool
who is really cool because we'll
actually see him wielding lightsabers
with that being said I will catch you
guys later peace be sure to follow me on
Twitter there you can keep up with all
the updates from comics explained and
talk to me directly get number the bad
guys and get some ass Scott plays
Renee's got bones galore
or with bear traps and hand grenades
pull the pistol like a maniac right in
your face
lop it off sleep in trailer cups sitting
on my chair scratching my nuts I can't
die I'm invincible but if you like to
try